[Music]
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists look around we are
busier and more stressed than ever we've
been told by many well-intentioned
people that it's necessary or even
virtuous to work hard to grind to toil
but what's the truth today on the
podcast we're talking about the toxicity
of hustle culture then this thursday on
the minimalist private podcast ryan and
i will discuss emotional intelligence
kindness and self-awareness you can
check that out at patreon.com
the minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me
advertisements suck
yeah they do ryan our first question
today is from sarah on facebook in a way
don't people say they're busy because
it's cool to say your life is full of
obligations let's talk about busyness
for a second ryan remember how it used
to be a badge of honor for us man
i still hear it all the time don't you
oh yeah in fact i often want to say it
during like small talk what are you up
to oh just real busy right now
now what am i saying when i say i'm busy
i'm really saying my life is out of
control
whenever i say i'm busy
i'm really saying i don't have control
of my calendar i don't have control of
my own obligations i don't have a
control over the things that i do from
day to day from hour to hour from minute
to minute so if i don't have control who
does it's everyone else who's permeating
my inbox
it's everyone else who is dictating what
i'm going to do on my calendar i'm
saying yes yes yes and i'm accidentally
saying no to the things that are most
important
and so
to address sarah's question head on yes
we quite often do it as ryan said as a
badge of honor it's almost become a a
status symbol
i'll paraphrase
thoreau
when he talks about it's not enough to
be busy the question is what are you
busy about
that's not a direct quote but that's the
essence of of the quote and so if i were
to append that the question is what are
you focused on
and right now we're so busy because
we're not very focused on the things
that matter to us it's very easy for us
to
just browse social media get on tick
tock or instagram or incessantly check
my email over and over and over
responding to everyone else's emergency
pretending as though just because
something's urgent to to jordan or
johnny jump up on the street it has to
be urgent to me
and it's really stressing us out
i've got this article here ryan called
the toxicity of hustle culture the grind
must stop
now
i don't agree with that either at least
the title maybe it's meant to just get
people
thinking about it here but i guess the
question is like what are you hustling
for we were supposed to have gary vee on
the podcast today
and i was really looking forward to that
but unfortunately he's too busy to be
here today
maybe because other people have control
of his time and he feels so busy he has
so many obligations and so he actually
pitched us asked us to be on the podcast
we didn't reach out to him to have him
on and i
i first i said no because it just didn't
make a whole lot of sense if if there's
anyone i disagree with more i can't
think of that person with respect to
being busy and hustling and grinding
it's not that i disagree with that for
him it's just it's so unappealing to me
now
because ryan back in our 20s
we lived a lot like that yeah 80 hours a
week yeah i mean we did it to ourselves
man you were talking about answering
emails and text messages and phone calls
and uh we the problem is we never said
no to anyone
and
that creates a very busy life yes um
so yeah you know that whole that whole
attitude of gtd get things done right i
mean that's that's what we were living
in and yeah you're right like being busy
was this badge of honor it was to the
point of
you know we would
belittle
our employees
if they weren't busy enough or heaven
forbid they took all their vacation
i mean remember like how much ridicule
people would get like they'd have two
weeks of vacation it's coming up on
holidays and they're like yeah if i
don't use it i lose it right um although
you could get paid for it instead of
taking the time off so that's what you
know the real
that's what the executives said they
didn't take their vacation they just you
know took the extra two weeks pay right
where we had you know employees that
were like no i'm gonna take the two
weeks that i have spent some time with
my family and man like we just uh yeah i
like i resent myself for looking down on
people like that and not supporting them
um
doing what they need to do to recharge
doing what they need to do to you know
keep their family life well instead yeah
we looked at them and we're like you're
so lazy yeah we treated it as a
character flaw yeah just because you
want time for yourself outside of work
whatever
it was a character flaw and the truth is
like if you want that fine if you don't
want that that's also fine and so i
think we need to identify maybe our
friend erwin mcmanus has been on the
podcast a few times he makes this great
distinction between
hurry and hustle
he's a big advocate of hustle and for
him what he means by hustle is like
being deeply compelled to do something
and working hard at that thing at which
you're deeply compelled to do almost a
sort of devotion to the work or to the
creativity
and that devotion
is what he considers to be hustle and
for me i have no problem with that in
fact
by that definition by that viewpoint
then i hustle a lot right yeah i think
the problem is especially back in our
corporate days or even now if i'm not
careful
i will do things hastily in a hurried
fashion john mark homer wrote this book
called the ruthless elimination of hurry
in alabama i think we're trying to get
him on on the podcast
and the the fascinating thing about
that is we have started to wear hurrying
as a badge of honor as well yeah it is
virtuous to be what efficient it's
virtuous to be what productive nothing
wrong with being efficient nothing wrong
with being productive in fact people
often think we the minimalists that's
the 10 people in this room or whatever
are
productive and we are productive in the
sense that we produce things that we
find to be meaningful creations we're
not productive in the sense that we must
produce more we must be more efficient
efficiency is great as a byproduct
productivity is great as a byproduct if
it becomes the point of doing what we're
doing then we're just going to be
hurried we're going to be hustling for
no reason yeah yeah so let's talk about
this article
your alarm rings and you wake up first
thing check your phone you go to the
bathroom then recheck your phone then
you eat breakfast while bolting out the
door and simultaneously scrolling
through emails when you finally make it
to work you scarf down meals in between
meetings when you finally quote finish
work
it still follows you home you continue
to check and respond to emails while
watching netflix and talking to your
family finally fall asleep despite all
the blue light in your home the next day
repeat does this sound familiar it
sounds pretty exhausting to me this
toxic cycle is called hustle culture the
societal standard that you must exert
yourself at 110 capacity to
hustle success doesn't take breaks
hustle culture doesn't sleep hustle
culture works day in and day out pushing
to maximize all
1440 minutes in every day you don't stop
when you're tired you stop when you're
done and throughout all of this you must
embrace the facade that you absolutely
love what you do
no matter the pain it may cause
the unfortunate thing about this ryan is
you can often
love doing something as that's the
vernacular they're using i would just
say you enjoy something you you enjoy
creating maybe you enjoy writing but as
soon as you put a real formalized
structure around it you can often stop
enjoying it i think about a writer who's
now forced to write a book they don't
want to write and they have a deadline
in order to do it yeah that thing that
you loved
now is draining to you yeah what's
interesting how like i think part of the
hustle culture is
you know find out what you're passionate
about and then hustle to make money from
that passion
and
what you just said like that's that is a
surefire way
to kill your passion right is to to to
make it your busy work yes because it
doesn't it doesn't get to be a get to
that now it turns into a have to and
there's nothing wrong with making money
from what you're passionate about like
don't get me wrong
but you know i have uh
i got a you know a friend who called me
the other day he's like oh i got this
really good idea for uh for a blog and
here's what i'm doing and you know i
know that you guys have a blog and uh uh
talk to me about monetizing it
and i'm like no dude i'm like if that's
the reason why you want to start a blog
like that's hey it's not going to last
and be like that's the wrong reason
you're going to hate the blog eventually
yeah and i would also apply that to
anything else that we've done we started
the podcast there was no monetization of
it there were no ads there was no
patreon
when we started touring we lost tons of
money touring
because all the events were free and we
would just show up and if we sold enough
books in one night we'd have enough
money for a hotel room and then the
money was gone maybe a meal yeah and
then the money was gone we'd do it all
over again it wasn't about monetizing
the thing the same is true with social
media we still don't monetize our social
media and even the blog there's we don't
make money directly off the blog there
are some things that it can lead to that
we can earn money from but money has
never been the point yeah and if it's
the point of doing what you do
then that's probably going to burn you
out yes over a long enough timeline
as you said there's no
there's no problem with making money i
want to earn a living i want to be able
to earn enough money to pay everyone in
this room yeah
and the where we get into trouble though
is now i feel compelled
by society not by this inner
compulsion to to create
to make something worthwhile but i feel
compelled by society here are the things
i'm supposed to do i'm supposed to say
yes to this meeting i'm supposed to say
yes to this person i'm supposed to say
yes to this project to this work to this
obligation to these hours
and
at first when you're starting saying yes
to a lot of things makes a lot of sense
because you don't know what to say no to
right away so try different things out
like as a baby when babies are first
trying food it's like you can tell
whether they like it or not right away
but the only way you can tell that is if
they try it out when you enter the
workplace it's the same thing i'll try
this out i'll try going to meetings on
monday mornings the problem is when you
and i clung to meetings for a dozen
years yeah
we have to go to a meeting we have to
show up and do this thing over feels so
important man oh i think that's the
other piece of it too right that's why
it's a badge of honor you feel important
you feel like you're making a
contribution
um well especially from where we came
from where you know none of our uh none
of our our parents or
you know um aunts uncles like none of
them were like these executives right so
we saw this
opportunity to have some influence oh
i'm an executive i'm i'm a manager i'm a
regional manager whatever it was
and uh yeah you get with the wrong
company then you have to be busy in
order to have that role and we never
stopped to ask ourselves why um like why
will this make me important and and okay
let's say it does make me important
why do i want to be important right
oh is it because i want to be validated
by someone else
okay is this the best way to get that
validation or
can i recognize the whole sham that
being validated by others is anyway
because
i
spent a lot of time making myself
miserable in order to be important
what an equation
introducing low-grade suffering into my
life
just so that i can seem
important to other people yeah how do i
become important over them i have to
have dominion over them yeah right and
so
the hustle culture leads to all of this
toxicity in fact there are five or maybe
ten things here what to do when you're
stuck in hustle culture i'm just going
to read a few of these podcasts john if
you put a link to this article in the
show notes i'd really appreciate it but
the
so it talks about the impacts of hustle
hustle culture it talks about some
different data they have here how we're
actually less productive the more we
hustle
so that's fascinating we think we're
doing something but really just spinning
our wheels
what to do when you're stuck in hustle
culture number one start with awareness
by becoming aware if you are in a cycle
of hustle culture you possess the
foundation
for change so of course yeah if you're
also aware that hey this thing that i'm
hustling for is making me miserable
that's a problem however if you're
hustling
and you feel so fulfilled and rewarded
by the hustle that you're doing great
why would you stop that yeah and so it
doesn't have to stop that's why i have
problems with articles like this they
treat it so binary hustle culture bad no
no toxic hustle culture
often makes us miserable
because of the hurry because of the
busyness because of the over obligation
but
hustling towards something that we
devote ourselves to
can be really beautiful yeah a couple
more things here acknowledge what's
important to you so
of course that's what we're talking
about here if you're hustling towards
something that is actually important to
you not i'm going to be important but
what is actually important to me yeah
man that's really helpful it makes me
think about um
yeah when i was just kind of going over
what was important to me after that
packing party where
i was listing out like oh man here are
the things that are important to me
and that was the the first step to
actually creating um some different
behavior in myself because i realized
that
hardly any of my actions actually
aligned with what was important to me no
wonder you were so discontented right
because when we're next week we're
talking with ian kron we actually
recorded this yesterday but we had a
podcast episode with ian kron and he
wrote sort of two definitive books on
the enneagram on personality tests and
identity so the episode next week is
about identity clutter and one of the
things that you talk about in depth
there i'll just touch on it briefly is
no wonder we're so miserable because
we feel all this shame
when our actions don't match our values
and so
what do we try to do quite often we try
to change our actions we try to change
what we're doing we try to hustle more
we don't stop to question what we're
valuing yeah what is actually important
to me yeah i'll read one more
yeah absolutely i'll read one more here
reward yourself now not later hustle
culture is built on the mantra that your
hard work will someday pay off break
this cycle by creating boundaries in
your schedule and reward yourself with
practices that will build your
resilience and prevent future burnout i
think that's one of the things that
people run into the burnout side of
things right i feel like i'm not getting
any fuel from this i've burped all of my
fuel by hustling hustling hustling what
am i really getting from this i'm
working 70 80 100 hours a week our
friend colin wright when he first
stumbled into minimalism it's because he
was working 100 to 120 hours a week
with his own design studio and he
realized like this is not sustainable
dude leads the burnout and i kind of
want to go into burnout but i know we
have a question about burnout so i will
save it well let's move on to amanda's
question or if you have a question for
us by the way or a minimalism tip give
us a call 406 219-7839
or email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com amanda in seattle
washington has a question for us when
you recognize that you know hustling is
leading you to a burnout
what is the advice on how to approach
that with your employer
i've seen a lot of people that just end
up
hitting that burnout and they end up
taking a lot of time off on fmla or you
know
how do you approach that with your
employer before that point
and what's your advice on where to go
from there
all right so let's let's talk about
burnout
and uh what leads to burnout what
happens
is you say yes to as many things as
possible
right and maybe it feels really good to
fulfill all these needs to help people
to contrib whatever it is whatever need
it's fulfilling because it's fulfilling
something right um
the problem is is that eventually
you you like look at your schedule you
look at your life and you're like oh my
god what have i done
how
how has it got to this point now here's
the problem with burnout if you're
already burned out
that's
you're in this situation where you think
it needs to be binary either i continue
to burn out or i quit my job
and that sucks because now you're in
this like pressure cooker situation
so um what i'm trying to say is if
you're already burnt out it's kind of
too late but that's okay um you can
still
create some boundaries and do some
things to help get out of the situation
but um i'm just thinking to myself where
i was so burnt out i'm like oh my god i
have to like i gotta quit my job right
yeah and in fact i think the reason that
we go toward that ryan is because
here's the problem we're talking about
she's what she's really asking amanda is
how do i reset expectations with my boss
as though
it's a one-time thing here's the problem
let's say you've worked there like you
and i were at the same company i was
there for a dozen years
for a dozen years my daily action set a
particular expectation yes and so if i
said hey i'm willing to work 90 hours a
week
then that was the expectation i was
setting and not only was i setting that
expectation once i was setting it every
day i was setting that expectation when
i was responding to emails
2 a.m or whatever it was right like
whenever i was constantly working hey
i'm my expectation was i'm willing to
out work everyone else and again nothing
wrong with that if that is the byproduct
but it became the point for me of here's
what i'm going to do i'm going to work
harder than you well why i don't know i
didn't stop to ask myself why and so the
unfortunately the simplest path at this
point amanda may be to find a similar
job
in the same
area
let's say you work in tech well finding
a different tech job there in seattle
may be easier for you to set those
expectations
with the clean slate yeah that's that's
a great idea i what it makes me think
about is what you did with our boss
when uh he was you were at the dinner on
christmas eve
and he's calling you
and you're like yeah you're out to
dinner yes and you're like no i'm not i
was on a date yeah like i know i'm not
answering this uh-huh and uh he just
kept calling and calling and calling
yeah eventually
like a crazy ex-boyfriend or
ex-girlfriend right yes right yeah 20
missed calls
yeah so then yeah you pick up the phone
hey what can i do for you
where are your sales at right now
where are your sales at how are your
stores doing
and you're like oh
you want me to tell you how my sale i
have no idea yeah it's six o'clock on
christmas eve and i'm out to dinner
right now
that's unacceptable like and you're like
no i think your your expectation is
unreasonable yeah that's the problem and
i think in a weird way we were both
right
yeah it was unacceptable in that culture
it was and so here's the weird thing
about so i did reset an expectation with
him hey i'm not going to answer your
phone calls anymore after 5 p.m and why
did why were you able to set that
expectation well two reasons
one is because i added so much value
that um i i was able to dictate some
terms right because i had some freedom
there now here's here's the honest
answer though
the dynamic of my work changed
significantly after that i was no longer
the prized employee there because of the
expectation of that culture of that
corporation was especially in these
middle management or upper upper
management roles you had to be
accessible like a doctor 24 hours a day
except we weren't saving anyone's lives
i couldn't even save my own life my own
life was in shambles but i was supposed
to be on call like a doctor and so
you're right i was able to reset an
expectation that gave me a longer runway
but ultimately
that expectation resetting
didn't change their expectations long
term and so i did have to find an exit
and that's what i would say to amanda
don't jump up and quit but if the
expectations of the culture you're not
going to change the culture of a company
true you can however find a company with
a culture that aligns with your values
go back and listen to our episode that
we did with ken coleman
recently he had a new book come out it
was a recent episode we'll put a link to
it in the show notes but amanda i'd love
to send you a couple tickets to our love
people use things tour event ryan and i
are in the middle of this tour it's 20
different cities all over the u.s and
canada we have 11 cities left we'll be
in new york and boston and d.c
we'll be in chicago and toronto and
minneapolis and columbus will be in
vancouver and los angeles and seattle
and san francisco you can find tickets
at theminimalists.com
tour if you can't make it to any of
those events though we're posting all 20
over on patreon patreon.com the
minimalist you can watch or listen to
all 20 of those events but amanda you
don't have to worry about that we're
going to send you a couple tickets to
the upcoming seattle event which is
taking place i think next month all
right man technically it's an
international tour man
because of canada yeah and if she wanted
she'd go to vancouver
it's just a little bit north that's
right come on up
the one thing i do want to say here
though is like when you're resetting
these expectations when you're telling
someone no it's not just looking at them
and saying no like it's really helping
them understand why you're saying no and
you do that by helping them understand
what you're saying yes
for yes
instead of saying no no no it's like the
same thing we talk about with christmas
gifts it's not about no no no don't give
me christmas with gifts ba humbug you
don't want to be ba humbug at work
either
you can say yes in fact i do this with
my daughter all the time how can we go
eat at tatsu ramen it's her favorite
restaurant yes we can do that next week
if you behave yourself between now and
then so i'm not saying no we're not
going there tonight because it's
effectively the same answer but i'm
saying yes
to some future
future expectation future desire for her
and you can do the same thing here you
can reposition it you can you can
reframe it in a way where we're saying
yes to the things that are truly
important and that might mean you have
to say no to some of the busy work some
of the hurry that's going on in your
life right now him alabama can we check
in with the patreon live stream do you
have any comments right now we have a
lot of listeners that are tuning in from
the uk sweden australia czech republic
denmark and so much more oh wow we have
uh you know we have no tour stops over
there right now quite a few travel
restrictions
but um we hope to see you as soon as uh
as soon as we're able to get to the
other side of this ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments to 937
you nailed it nailed it those those
texts actually go to both of our phones
this weekend i uh hopped on right i
probably spent i spent i had on friday
four or five hours responding to maybe
500 different text messages
sometimes i'll just i'll just go in and
answer real quickly or here yeah they'll
ask a question i'm like we just did a
video about this how come they haven't
seen them of course they haven't seen it
so i'll just send them a link to the
video or the last some long question or
short question i'll just send them some
sort of pithy response so
we don't answer every question we do
answer occasionally some here on the
show so during the lightning round this
is where ryan and i do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maxims in the
show notes so you can copy and share or
pick the answers on social media if you
like and now you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place minimal
maxims.com todd has a question for us i
made the hard decision of giving up my
career after 16 years because the stress
was killing me
how do i get past the pressure to go
after another traditional career a big
house a nice car so
this is actually my this is tweetable i
know because i tweeted it to make sure
but this is an excerpt from an essay
that i just wrote so during our right
here right now segment where we talk
about one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist we have a brand
new essay up on the website it's called
nobody has the power to upset you
love it this was really uh helpful for
me yesterday um
but uh this is an excerpt from that
essay we're going to talk about it on
the maxwell episode a bit more but
here's my pithy answer what others think
what they believe what they expect these
are bars to a prison cell to break free
you must realize that those bars are
lining their cage not yours you can walk
away at any point
so ryan let's talk about these
expectations really what he's talking
about here
you may not want the
traditional career the big house the
nice car these are things that other
people want and they also want you to
want them or at least that's what you
think you think they want you to be in a
big house maybe they'll appreciate you
more maybe they'll love you more maybe
they'll care about you more maybe
they'll need you more if you have more
of these resources right but that's a
type of prison
but those prison bars are theirs they're
trapped by that yeah they're trapped by
their need for a bigger house for a
fancier car for an important job title
yeah you don't have you can walk away
from those bars they're not yours to
hold on to what we were talking about um
this isn't my pithy answer but it could
maybe it could be pithy but the whole uh
uh when you when you let your
expectations be dictated by society it
can only create anxiety yeah
i mean that's the problem is like we are
yes we're letting others create our uh
our
our needs are once um here's my fifth
answer when you sacrifice your
contentment all that remains is
discontentment yes so it sounds real
simple but we don't appreciate that
enough no every time you say yes to
something
and it creates and sacrifices some type
of uh contentment in your life then
you're just creating more room for
discontentment now
we gotta pay taxes josh
we gotta we gotta fill up paperwork we
gotta be on the road there are things
that we don't necessarily want to do
but we have to sacrifice a little bit to
get to where we want the problem is when
we sacrifice too much or we sacrifice
our values
yes absolutely yeah 100
so
what what is important to you we often
ask that question but here's the truth
right now whatever you're doing right
now is literally by definition and by
its very essence whatever you're doing
right now is the most important thing to
you so if you are on tick tock scrolling
through videos that is the number one
most important thing to you if you're on
instagram
checking out
butts and cleavage fine but just
recognize that is the most important
thing to you right now if you're in a
podcast studio in los angeles and you're
recording a podcast that's the most
important thing to you right now if
you're checking email that's the most
important thing to you right now if
you're driving to work that in that
moment driving to work is the most
important thing to you if you're out
running five miles and you're listening
to this podcast that is the most
important thing to you if you're cooking
dinner for your family that is the most
important thing to you if you're simply
wasting time and you feel
miserable doing it well then maybe
you might want to change what is
actually important to you because
whatever you're doing
is the most important thing right now
yeah matt you know the one thing i'll
say uh with todd's question too
is
he he's talking about wanting the bigger
house wanting the nice car
and again when you and i were kind of
having a conversation about this about
this lightning round question
um i had mentioned that you know when we
when we have the appropriate
relationships in our lives like the
appropriate like good relationships in
our lives a lot of these urges
uh they're not as as big so you know uh
shameless plug of our book love people
use things we talk about seven important
relationships yes with people but also
with finances also with creativity also
uh
you know with with the other four four
other uh relationships we have in there
but the thing is
is that when you have healthy
relationships in your life
you don't look for these shortcuts
because that's that's what this is
the big house the nice car this is a
shortcut to ephemeral happiness and yeah
you know what if you had a lamborghini
in a multi-million dollar mansion you're
gonna feel happy for about six seconds
until you gotta like take care of those
things until you have to like continue
to work to to to uh to maintain those
things so todd i would just really
encourage you to really focus on
those
important relationships in your life
making sure that those are healthy
and then maybe look at these desires
because i still
you know i'll try in la man there's just
like millions and millions of dollars
everywhere right yes like i'll drive
past the mansion and for a split second
you know mariah will be in the car with
me and i'll be like that's a really cool
house that's a nice looking house man
wouldn't it be cool to own something
like that but then you know and we can
kind of talk about it and you know like
daydream about like oh in order to
afford that we'd have to like win the
lottery or something but then i can
quickly dismiss it
and say like do i really want that like
no i don't want all that extra space
what's the cost of that thing yeah
there's so much more cost than the
monetary cost of it and it's very easy
for me to
ignore that and i think that has to do
with my theory is is because i have a
good relationship with mariah i have a
good relationship with you i have a good
relationship with everyone else who
works for us i have a
good relationship with my finances and
everything so i'm not looking for the
shortcuts and todd i would just posit
that maybe there's some other things you
could focus on first before looking for
the shortcuts here's a concise way to
look at that because i think you're spot
on you have a wonderful relationship a
healthy relationship with
enough
what is enough and you can see those
things and you can appreciate them oh
wouldn't it be cool to have that house
or that lamborghini or whatever but you
recognize i already have enough and that
might be too much for a whole host of
reasons it's a too much money too much
insurance too much taking care of the
thing too much worrying about the thing
all of these additional costs and i
think this is the difference between a
want and a desire a want is like oh yeah
i really want to buy that new range
rover wouldn't it be nice to have that
a one to some oh that'd kind of be nice
to have without me really thinking about
the depths of the discontent it might
cause
a desire however a desire means i'm
willing to somewhat sacrifice for that i
feel so compelled that i'm willing to
devote myself to that and
that has nothing to do with
a car yeah you can't be it's almost
impossibly passionate about buying a
lamborghini you might have to get
excited about it yeah but passion
the root of passion means to suffer so
if you're willing to suffer for
something that you can devote yourself
to
then you deeply desire it if it'd just
be nice to have that's just a want yeah
and you can let go of the want
and instead pursue something that is
worth suffering for yeah and i want to
be clear like there's nothing wrong with
having a nice house there's nothing
wrong with having a nice car the problem
is when it costs you your peace
that is and that's where todd's at he's
like oh
i might i still want to give up my piece
for this and that's that's what we're
we're really suggesting you look at you
know this is parable in the bible that
has never made sense to me jesus talks
about this man who wanted a pearl
he wanted it so badly
and he he like he was on the hunt for
this pearl
and eventually
he found one and he dropped everything
for it gave up everything for and he was
so happy he had this pearl and the
parable is like well see god like that
but i don't understand that parable with
the pearl because it seems so silly to
give up everything for one little pro
have you heard of this parable at all it
reminds me of a sufi parable that's it's
fairly similar
but it's um where this guy runs into
this mystic and and he goes i just you
you the mystic had this beautiful like
the largest diamond in the world i'm
gonna butcher the parable you'll get the
the point of and here he goes oh i would
do anything to get the that it's the
most beautiful diamond in the world my
life would be so much better with it and
the mystic just hands it over to him
says here you go
and then so he has it now he's like oh
why don't i feel any better and a day
goes by a week goes by a month goes by
he goes back to the mystic and he goes
if i give this back to you will you show
me
how you can just give it away so easily
and so the willingness to let go
yeah is really what he was searching for
he was searching for the contentment
he was searching for knowing he already
had enough and he didn't need the
biggest diamond in the world or anything
else leading up to it because that
mystic already had enough oh man there's
something there with like letting go of
the desire
and yeah it's it's like um
you don't have to wait to find the pearl
or the diamond to to have the
willingness to let go like you can skip
the difficult part that's right and just
focus on letting go you know
a lot of times like we have
conversations like this and people will
um kind of look at it like well this is
selfish you don't you know you don't
want to just tell people no all the time
and you know you don't want to um
you know just put your own needs first
sure and if you're only if you're
putting only your needs first then yes
like that's a problem but when it comes
to your peace and contentment it's it's
totally appropriate to set some
boundaries and to set some expectations
and i feel like sometimes people are
afraid of coming off as selfish
but really
when you are putting your when you're
putting your piece
first and you're asking people around
you to help with that
um that in a way it's i think it's
selfless actually
yeah and if anything it's
self-interested without it being selfish
and even if it is selfish so what what's
the alternative i'm selfless but
miserable yeah right who wants that and
so when we're behaving in these ways
where your actions align with your
values you have a a healthier
relationship with those seven
relationships you talked about earlier
whether it's your stuff or with other
people or with the truth or with your
finances you have these healthy
relationships yes it's self-serving but
it's also serving others and what a
beautiful symbiotic relationship that is
yeah right i got a silly added value
segment i want to get to in a minute but
malabama you got something for us first
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hi justin ryan this is claudia in santa
barbara i have a tip that i thought of
when josh was talking about his mostly
empty filing cabinet because i remember
my mostly empty filing cabinet
i realized that this tip might be a
little regional and not be as convenient
or available to everyone but many banks
offer a low cost or even free safe
deposit box for their customers i keep
all of our important papers and things
like birth certificates wills passports
and social security cards in the safe
deposit box at a bank less than a mile
away from our home
i replaced my mostly empty filing
cabinet with a small clear accordion
file that holds copies not originals of
what is in the safe deposit box along
with one of the keys to the box taped
inside
those hard copies are mostly for someone
else who might need to know where the
originals are but another set of copies
is saved digitally on my computer
another tip is that at that same bank
they will take bags of paper to shred so
when i have more than a couple of sheets
i just take them in and ask them to
shred them for me
hi this is amanda from bloomington
indiana
and i have a small tip for maya from the
episode 202 by once i purchase food for
two people now since i live with my
fiance so i started to notice i was
spending more in my budget
the way i found to keep the overall cost
down is to plan out your dinners and
meals for the week not necessarily meal
prepping ahead of time but just planning
out what you want to make every night
this helped me get in and out of the
store while avoiding picking up extra
unnecessary snack items and having a
menu helped encourage me to cook at home
it also got me more excited about the
actual act of cooking so i started
looking forward to cooking at home
instead of coming home and dreading it
and then end up buying something out to
eat
all right y'all for our added value
segment real quick right i'm gonna go
into depth on this on the maximal
episode have you heard of mewing
no there's a doctor from the uk his name
is dr mike mew and he specializes in
facial posture but joel posture tongue
posture in particular oh wow and he has
this technique called mewing part of it
has to do with hard chewing we've really
lost our essence we
back in the day
15 000 years ago humans chewed a lot
more difficult things to chew whether it
was tubers or raw meat or
different vegetables that are really
fibrous we and now we're like eating
smoothies we're not chewing the same way
and it's doing terrible things to our
jawlines it's the reason you see these
epidemics of crooked teeth because our
mouths aren't they no longer fit our
teeth but if you look at video of like
the messiah over in africa they've never
seen a dentist in their lives
but they have some of the most beautiful
big broad smiles and it has to do with
you know they're effectively mewing into
us and it's a five-step process there's
this guy named matt phelps who has a
video
um about this i'm gonna put a link to it
in the show notes but there's also i've
been chewing this mastic gum which is 10
times harder than regular gum it has no
flavor basically it kind of tastes a
little bit like ginger but it's really
hard and you chew actually with the
front of your mouth anyway check out
matt phelps's video if you're interested
in this because what it does is you see
these people with over the course of a
year they totally transform the way
their whole face looks not everyone has
a big beautiful
manly joel line like you i still got
crooked teeth and part of that the
reason for that is there's a a shrinkage
there
making more space you actually see
people transform their faces anyway
we'll put a link to matt phelps's video
in the show notes we'll talk a bit more
about it on the private podcast this
week by the way ryan we have a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
how do i prepare myself adequately to
have uncomfortable conversations with
other people how do i establish
boundaries with others without being
accused of being oversensitive i finally
quit my stressful career after 30 years
how do i figure out what my next move is
plus a million more questions for the
minimalists and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com the
minimalists to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tiktok instagram facebook and twitter at
the minimalists if you want our podcast
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at theminimalists.com
on behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social jess danny
unknown emma the immigrant oh we have
jacob in here from book light as well
i'm joshua fields melbourne reminding
you to love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it